great uh so let's get started for today
okay so let's get started for today uh
today we're going to be talking about
bayesian med learning uh and
specifically we'll talk about why
what are the benefits of
this class of approaches
will describe um different ways to
integrate kind of asian graphical models
into metal learning approaches both for
black box approaches and optimization
based approaches
and then finally we'll talk about
evaluation and the different kinds of
things that you can do when you have a
bayesian metal learning algorithm
uh by the end of the lecture the goal is
for you to be able to understand the
interpretation of metal learning within
a bayesian inference framework
and also understand the techniques for
representing uncertainty over parameters
and over predictions
um disclaimers similar to the lecture on
monday
this is a very active area of research
and also like most of the class content
so there's going to be more questions
than answers and
uh the lecture was also going to cover
some of the most advanced in some of the
mathias topics of this course i'll do my
best to
go slowly and uh
and uh
hope to um hope to still be able to
convey the
intuition uh so please ask questions
throughout based on what is uh
based on yeah the content
um i also see a message in the chat
about being able to
reached out to a ta download do that and
so i hope that ta will will upload the
slides very soon
um
so they'll be available whenever the the
ta gets to it
okay cool so a recap from
last week uh we talked about different
metal learning approaches and we
specifically looked we specifically
overviewed two different perspectives on
meta learning algorithms
the first perspective was the
perspective of a computation graph
and we saw how we could view different
kinds of approaches within the same
perspective
of
past a computation graph that takes his
input training data and a test input and
processes it either with a black box
function with an optimization or with a
non-parametric computation
so this was the first perspective that
we covered and then we also thought
about the algorithms from their
algorithmic properties
where one property was thinking about
the expressive power of the metal
learner and another property was
thinking about the consistency of the
metal learner
and these two properties were are both
quite important for a lot of
applications
and there was a third
property that we mentioned on wednesday
last week where you're talking about
uncertainty awareness
where we want to be able to reason about
ambiguity during the learning process
which may help in a variety of
situations such as active learning and
reinforcement learning and also bring in
some
principled probabilistic interpretations
to these algorithms
and this this kind of last property is
exactly what we're going to be talking
about today
so
first let's talk about some motivation
and the benefits that this
interpretation gives us
so
earlier in the course we talked about
how at training and test time
we want things to match
uh
and we also talked about how the tasks
have to share some amount of
structure
but we never really went into what
structure means
what does it mean for toss to share
structure what is that structure
and one way to kind of get a handle on
this question is to think about that
structure as
a statistical dependence on some shared
information
where that shared kind of information is
latent it's not something that we can
directly observe
and in particular we can consider this
graphical model here uh which uses plate
notation
where you have some
kind of
shared latent information theta
this has this kind of there's a
dependence from the shared information
to each of the task parameters phi i
uh and i'm using the plate here to
denote that there are kind of
eyes indexing the different tasks the
test specific parameters for each of our
tasks
and then there's also dependence from
the top specific parameters to
the labels
uh conditioned on the kind of inputs
so this is
this part right here is essentially
g train for task i
and
these two variables over here correspond
to d test
for task i
and j is indexing the
the data points within those data sets
and the
everything that is shaded means that
it's observed so we can always observe d
train
but at meta test time we can only
observe x test we can't observe y test
that's what we're trying to predict
um
it's kind of partially shaded because we
do get to observe y test during the
metatrading process
so this is uh in many ways a graphical
model that explains
the
kind of data generation process in a
meta learning setting
and
there's a couple things that you can do
that this this graphical model can
potentially tell you about the meta
learning process
so first if you condition on the
the latent task in from the latent
shared information theta
then we see that the task parameters
become independent
so we know that uh
the task specific parameters for one
task and other tasks become independent
once you condition on all of the
information that they share
and second
if you don't condition on this
information then the tasks are
not statistically independent
and hence if uh
if there is shared information then you
actually have lower entropy
uh
so essentially when you condition on
theta that gives you more information
or hence lowers your entropy over the
distribution for the task specific
parameters phi i
um so basically this equation is telling
you that
as you
as you kind of conditioned onto shared
information
you now have a better idea for what the
task specific parameters might be
they're telling you information about
these task specific parameters
okay so this is um
one of the things that this graphical
model can
tell us a bit about or help us think
about what's going on in this sort of
metal learning or multi-task learning
setting
now one thought exercise um
if you can identify the top specific
parameter sorry the the shared
parameters theta the shared information
data for example with metal learning
in what situations should learning the
task specific parameters be faster than
learning from scratch
does anyone want to share thoughts
either in chat or by raising your hand
or any questions about what i was uh
talking about here
uh
yeah and one question so
if knowing fire doesn't mean like
extreme and
extend white is independent of x i test
y test
yeah so once you know the top specific
parameters then the training set and the
test set are
independent uh and this is because we
assume that our training set and our
test set are sampled iid they're sampled
kind of independently from the task
distribution so once you know the task
then these can be independent
during training
from extreme at
yeah so a test time kind of our goal is
to figure out uh
what is basically
is to kind of figure out the
distribution of our task specific
parameters
once we have
d train
and theta
uh and once you're trying to kind of
figure this out um
like it's uh
yeah it's not
well i guess they're not independent but
still d train and detest are are
independent
um if you don't know what phi i is then
then they're not independent
so getting back to the thought exercise
um
one
one thought that had in the chat is if
the mutual information between theta and
phi i
is high
um then
this should be faster than learning from
scratch and so basically i think what
it's saying is that basically if there's
like a lot of shared information or a
kind of pretty heavy dependence
from phi i to think from theta to phi i
then you would expect it to be faster
than learning from scratch
and that's
largely true
any other thoughts
okay so one other thought here um also
is if you're learning from scratch then
you're basically learning from d train i
without
knowing the shared information theta
and so if
if all of the shared information theta
if that kind of that shared latent
information tells you something about
phi i
uh that d train doesn't tell you then
that's something that's a situation
where we'd expect to be faster than
learning from scratch because when
you're learning from scratch you only
have the training data you don't have
the shared information
um
so basically it's when you have high
mutual information but also when that
information isn't available in the
training data already
okay um and then
a second thought exercise
is what happens when
the entropy of this distribution right
here
is zero uh and specifically
what happens when uh
when entropy of the distribution is zero
it means that you can basically
determine deterministically figure out
what phi i should be
if you know what theta is
uh and for all i would suggest that if
you can deter basically you can
determine figure out what phi i is for
all i given theta
yeah and then said in the chat this will
um if this happens then that means that
the theta vector contains all of the
information needed to solve the tasks
uh and kind of the corollary to that is
if it has all the information then you
don't actually need to pay attention to
g train
and it kind of looks a bit like the
memorization problem that we talked
about before um
and you can get basically perfect yeah
as you can get a perfect score even in
the zero shot setting for example
okay so these are a couple of different
kind of
ways to have exercises or things that um
that are nice to look at in the
like basically kind of things that the
bayesian probabilistic modeling
framework can tell you and allows you to
reason about in a very formal way
which is pretty nice and gives some
intuition for
why you would expect metal learning to
provide some benefits compared to
learning from scratch um in the
situations in which you would expect
that to be true
um so that's one motivation uh
and then more concretely
what information might we expect fatigue
to contain
in different situations so
say for example our task distribution is
a family of sinusoid functions that vary
in terms of the amplitude in the phase
any thoughts on what information would
be contained within theta
that family of tasks
yeah so
said that uh
kind of the
what theta would contain the unit
sinusoid that it would contain sinusoid
function functions
um do you want to give an opinion
yeah i guess similar answer just the
function itself but things like
amplitude and frequency those can depend
on phi
yeah exactly so if different functions
vary based on their amplitude and phase
then you'd expect theta to contain
everything but that task specific
information so essentially theta will
contain
correspond to kind of that family of
sinusoid functions in a way that is
agnostic to
the um to the
phase and the
amplitude
and then when you
go from kind of theta to
by i uh and also kind of infer
infer phi i from data it's going to be
looking to that data to figure out what
the amplitude in the phase is
yeah so it essentially corresponds to
the general structure of sinusoid
functions
um
cool
okay now what about um one more example
so say that we were trying to
translate between different languages
uh and we wanted to quickly learn
a model that can translate between a new
language with a small amount of data
in this case what is the information
that theta might contain
feel free to answer and chat or raise
your hand
yeah so
the family of language pairs of the
grammatical structures
uh and and this is right so
uh
basically theta will correspond to this
family of language pairs it will
correspond to
the the shared structure among languages
it won't tell you things about like
vocabulary for example or things that
are specific to a certain language
okay um and then it's also worth
mentioning that the theta the kind of
information stored in theta is uh
is going to be narrower than the space
of all possible functions
uh if theta was basically the space of
all possible functions then we wouldn't
have any benefit
um from actually leveraging the
information and theta to solve a new
task
um and now one last thought exercise uh
is what happens if you might learn
without
without a lot of tasks if you only had a
small number of tasks and you ran metal
learning on that how would that affect
the information in theta
so i said overfitting which is
on the right track but which is correct
uh
any kind of more specific thoughts on
how this affects the information in
theta
yeah so i said that if you're over
fitting then theta will be
too narrow
and
basically kind of what can happen in
this case is
if you have a set of a small set of
training tasks or training functions
then you'll get this form of like meta
overfitting where
it considers not only the kind of
not only like for example a family of
sinusoid functions but only the set of
sinusoid functions that are in your
metatrading set it's going to basically
be a narrower set of tasks
um because it will kind of overfit to
the tasks that are in the training set
um rather than considering the
underlying
distribution of functions
okay
uh any any questions on this before we
move on to methods
yeah regarding the meta overfitting i i
guess maybe this point
should i see my question is
this point maybe it's related to your uh
use case of the overall meta learning
model right i mean you're intuitively
thinking if your use case is generally
narrower then that means you have more
like shared structures information in
your different meta tasks and that
should increase or at least intuitively
the performance of your model so
compared to like you have a very wide
use case and you train on a very diverse
set of tasks
yeah so if you have a very narrow
distribution of tasks then you may not
need as many samples from that
distribution because you may be able to
cover that with this cover that
distribution with a smaller number of
tasks
and so if you have a small number of
tasks but your distribution is also
narrow then you may not actually see
meta overfitting um it will just be kind
of fitting that more narrow distribution
whereas if you have a very large
distribution of tasks
in a small number of tasks sampled from
that distribution then you're much more
likely to see meta overfitting
in a way that isn't actually capturing
the full space of tasks
yeah thanks
okay um asking can we view meta
parameter theta as a good prior from the
bayesian perspective
and yeah that's basically right so you
can view theta as
uh
as kind of a prior over phi
and then when you're doing when you're
trying to estimate phi
given theta in your data you can view
that as like a form of posterior
inference
uh and then there's also a question why
everything but phase and amplitude so
phase and amplitude
in this problem are the things that are
task specific
and the general family of tasks is kind
of the family of of sinusoids for
different phases in amplitude and so
theta is capturing the shared
information and the phase and the
amplitude are the thing that isn't
shared across tasks
okay
cool so
then there's our last bit of motivation
um recall that kind of so far we've been
basically inferring
a set of parameters
phi i
given a training data set and theta and
so far we've just been like learning a
function that outputs phi i
deterministically
uh it's essentially giving us a point
estimate to
this distribution p
um and this is fine in a number of
different situations like in your
homework this was fine
but there are some situations where we
may want to actually express this
distribution this full distribution
rather than only giving a point estimate
of phi i
for example if you only have a really
small number of data points
then the true function may actually be
ambiguous even if you have a prior
uh so for example maybe you're trying to
learn a classifier
between
these images and these images
uh
and the challenge is if you want to kind
of learn a classifier all the images on
the left are people that are smiling
wearing a hat and young and all the
people on the right are people who are
not smiling not wearing a hat and not
young
and so if you want to learn a classifier
and then you're given this example of
someone who's smiling and wearing a hat
but not young
you don't it's kind of ambiguous what
the true answer is you don't know if
this classifier is intended to
discriminate on uh age or discriminate
on these other attributes
so
in these sorts of cases where the
problem is ambiguous it would be nice to
be able to represent our uncertainty
about this classifier
and then as a result be able to
represent our uncertainty about this
test image
okay um another
situation where we may want to be able
to represent this distribution is if we
want to be able to
generate hypotheses about the underlying
function
uh if we want to be able to sample from
this distribution then we need to
somehow uh somehow represent that
distribution
and once we can generate hypotheses then
we may be able to
kind of ask a user about which
hypothesis is correct for example
um
and if you're kind of in a safety
critical setting such as like medical
imaging for example it's important to be
able to
communicate your uncertainty about the
function to the user
uh so you can get a second opinion for
example
if you want to actively learn by
actively asking for data then this sort
of uncertainty is really helpful because
it tells you
uh
which data points would be helpful for
learning
for example in this kind of
classification example if you get
another example of someone who's filing
wearing a hat and young that's not going
to be very helpful for learning your
classifier
instead it's instead kind of labels of
these data points that would be most
helpful for
reducing your uncertainty about the
function
um it's worth mentioning that there's
actually a fair amount of work on active
learning with meta learning we won't go
into it during the lectures in this
course but if you're interested in
learning more there's a couple
references on the side
uh and lastly this is also pretty
helpful and important for learning to
explore in meta reinforcement learning
and we'll talk about this a bit more
in um
i think in like a week and a half or two
weeks
okay uh it looks like there's a question
in the chat uh saying is also learning
over
is learning a distribution over phi i
providing some sort of meta
regularization
um
yeah so one of the benefits of of
bayesian approaches is also is that they
often provide some implicit forms of
regularization
to encourage the model to represent
represent its uncertainty rather than
overfitting to kind of a single solution
that it thinks might be the right answer
but isn't quite the right answer
is also asking is active learning
equivalent to exploration in rl um
they are a little bit different from a
mechanistic point of view when you
actively learn typically it corresponds
to
asking for queries like querying a user
about the label for a specific data
point whereas exploration you have a
policy that is trying to
collect data in the environment in a
targeted way they both correspond to
kind of targeted data collection
but active learning is more often in a
supervised learning context whereas
exploration is more in a reinforced
learning context where you have an agent
in the environment
he's asking isn't active learning
uh
to interactive learning um
yeah i think that i guess active
learning is the the more formal term
that i've i've
i've heard in the machine learning
community but i think that
uh there may be interactive learning may
also be kind of a subfield uh
of active learning
okay
so now let's talk about some approaches
for
actually
developing bayesian med learning
approaches that can actually represent
their uncertainty and represent these
distributions
so uh it'll be helpful first to kind of
go back to the computation graph
perspective where you can view each of
these metal learning algorithms as
producing a prediction over y
given your training data set and your
test input
and really the first uh like v zero of a
bayesian metaling algorithm is instead
of having f
deterministically output um
output a label
habit output the parameters of a
distribution over y-test
um or otherwise outputted distribution
uh this is actually technically what
kind of a softmax cross-entry loss will
already do it's already representing a
soft max distribution over the discrete
values
but if you do regression and use a mean
squared error loss
you'll only be getting like the mean of
a gaussian distribution you won't be
getting the variance
but anyway i
you can have f i'll put the parameters
of a distribution this can be
probability values in a discrete
categorical distribution it can be the
mean and variance of a gaussian it could
be the parameters of a mixture of
gaussians
or if you have a multi-dimensional
y-test
then you could use an auto-regressive
model to kind of output a sequence of
distributions where you're outputting
something like
uh
like p of y1
and p of y 2 given y 1 and so forth
and then once you output this
distribution you can optimize
it with maximum likelihood
uh so this is pretty simple
this will give you kind of a
distribution over
your label for
the test inputs
um
it's also easy to combine with a variety
of methods you just need to have the
output of your model be a distribution
but it doesn't quite solve the problem
that we're after
it doesn't allow you to reason about
uncertainty about the underlying
function so this only gives you
basically
a distribution over
y test
given
x test d train
and theta it doesn't
so it basically gives you this
it doesn't
give you
a distribution over phi i
uh and it'd be nice to have kind of this
distribution because this allows you to
think about the underlying function
rather than just the
individual data points
um it's also limited there's also kind
of a limited class of distributions that
you can represent over y test
if you instead represent a distribution
over phi i then you may be able to get a
more expressive
distribution over a y test
and lastly this kind of approach
actually tends to produce poorly
calibrated uncertainty estimates
neural networks tend to
uh
overfit
in some sense this allows you to
represent the uncertainty over noise in
the data but it doesn't allow you to
represent uncertainty with regard to the
model parameters itself
um and if for example you you give it an
auto distribution input then this this
kind of approach tends to give you
uncertainty estimates that are over
confident
okay
and then
asking in the in the chat is learning
the distribution more difficult
uh yes in general these basic metal
learning algorithms uh
lead to a kind of a more difficult
optimization process because
you care not about just producing a
single
um a single value of your task specific
parameters or a single output of your y
you need to actually represent that full
distribution which leads to a kind of
which makes it more challenging to uh
to
optimize
asking can you explain the last con
again
so
to put it in another way there's
um there's two types of uncertainty one
type of uncertainty is
uh what's called aliatoric uncertainty
and this is uncertainty that's inherent
to
the data um to noise in the data
and this kind of approach and
tends to be reasonable at capturing that
kind of noise in the data
the
um the other type of uncertainty is
called
epistemic uncertainty which captures the
uncertainty in your model itself
and this kind of approach tends to
actually be quite poor at estimating the
uncertainty of the model
and
what i mean by uncertainty over the
model is
uh
when you have kind of out of
distribution data for example or data
that's a little bit different
then
your model isn't going to perform as
well because it hasn't seen that kind of
data
and so you want to be able to represent
your uncertainty over your model
parameters for those data points
and this approach tends to be
actually quite ineffective
at
representing that form of model
uncertainty
yeah so um i think that
question is um also asking what's the
difference between referring um p of y
test versus
uh pfi i can't we just infer p of y test
front view by i that's true once we have
pfi we can kind of sample from this
distribution at the top
but we can't go the other way around we
can't figure out pfi
um
from
poi test and
this kind of leads to this thought
exercise right here which is that
if we can do maximum likelihood training
on this distribution right here well why
can't we just do the same kind of
maximum likelihood
training for this ladder distribution
here
any thoughts on
why or why not um basically why or why
not we can't do maximum likelihood
training on this ladder distribution
yeah so said that we don't actually know
the actual phi
uh we don't have labels for
for phi i um and therefore we can't do
kind of supervised training on this
distribution
because we don't have the labels um if
we did have the labels then we could do
this but we don't um and that's why we
could only kind of do maximum likelihood
training for this and not for this
without introducing kind of extra
assumptions or approximations
okay um it's asking is it required that
the label y be a distribution during
during a mediterrane
when mediterranean invasion model
um
i guess there you can view
um point estimates as kind of
approximating
a bayesian distribution for example if
you train
uh a model with mean squared error you
can view that as
this as the output from the model as the
mean of a gaussian
but if you want to kind of truly
represent the distributions underlying a
probabilistic model then you'll want to
represent the full
distribution
um
and then lastly asking does a patient
better learning approach work only with
optimization based metal learning um so
this version works with any kind of
metal learning algorithm you just need
to have your
your y test you just need to output a
distribution over y test rather than a
deterministic
prediction
um
in the next part of the lecture we'll
talk about kind of
various ways to
get a distribution over phi i
it's both for black box methods and for
optimization based methods
okay
great so
before we actually dive into algorithms
for getting
uh a distribution over our task specific
parameters
i want to briefly overview
the kind of toolbox that we have for
approaching problems in bayesian deep
learning
this is just a really broad one slide
overview that kind of will give a sense
for the tools that are out there
cs236 provides a thorough treatment of
this
if you're interested in learning more
and of course we don't have time to go
through an entire course
today
so the general goal of the toolbox is to
be able to represent distributions with
neural networks
and there are a variety of techniques
that allow you to do this
one of the most popular techniques
and one of the most successful
techniques is to use what's called
latent variable models
along with
variational inference
and
these models try to do
try to approximate maximum likelihood
trading
using um
try to approximate maximum likelihood
trading within a latent variable model
and the way they do this is they
optimize a lower bound
on the likelihood
and we'll actually get into some of the
details of this method or this approach
on the next slide
and what i mean by kind of a latent
variable model is that you have your
observed data and you have some late
unobserved latent variable
uh and this will allow you to better
represent the distribution over the data
itself
uh the second class of methods is or a
second class of methods is bayesian
ensembles
uh this gives you a particle-based
representation of a distribution that
basically gives you samples from a
distribution
and the way that it works is you just
train separate models on different
bootstraps of the data so you basically
resample the data a few times train
models on different samplings of the
data
and then the different models give you
basically different
different estimates or different samples
from
your distribution
so these are the kind of
two of the more
popular approaches and two of the more
approaches that we'll talk about today
um
a couple other approaches one is
bayesian neural networks which
represents a distribution over the space
of parameters and this is similar to the
kind of regularization that we were
talking about
last time to combat memorization
um lastly there's also normalizing flows
which allows you to represent an
invertible function
between a latent distribution and a data
distribution
and can allow you to essentially warp
things from a gaussian distribution for
example to a more interesting non-linear
space
oh and then lastly there's also energy
based models and gans
these estimate an unnormalized density
of your distribution
and the way that they work is they tend
to try to
push down the data
and to basically kind of represent a
lower energy for the data and push up
everything else this is kind of akin to
a discriminator that's saying is trying
to say like the data is good and
everything else that's generated by the
generator is
not on the data manifold
um so that's kind of a summary of the
toolbox we're really going to be
focusing on the first two classes of
methods today
and specifically we'll look at how we
can leverage these first two in the
context of metal learning
the others could also be useful in
developing new methods
any questions about this kind of
one slide overview of bayesian deep
learning
okay
um so
we're first going to look at how
variational methods can
variational latent variable models can
allow us to
build a bayesian meta learning method
and so i'd like to give some background
on
how these methods work
and in particular
in a simplified setting
where we have just kind of
a set of data points x maybe of n of
those data points
the
we assume that we have kind of this
latent variable z
uh that underlies our data and our goal
is going to be to represent a
distribution over x
and we want to represent a expressive
distribution because maybe x is images
where x is language and
we want to be able to capture something
that's more complex than like a gaussian
distribution over images for example
um so x is the observed m variable and z
is the latent variable
and then essentially what variational
gives us is uh the evidence lower bound
that basically tells us that the
likelihood of our data
is lower bounded by
this expression right here
which is basically the um
samples from this variational
distribution q
uh
well an expectation over samples from
this variational distribution of the log
probability of the joint
plus
the
plus the entropy of our variational
distribution
um and perhaps the more common way to
write this is something that looks like
the
kind of likelihood of samples decoded
from
our latent space
minus the kl divergence between
our variational distribution and our
prior over z
so uh before i go forward i guess
i'm curious for how many people would it
be helpful if i actually kind of derived
this bound
um
on
a whiteboard like
thing
so maybe um
maybe say yes if that would be helpful
and know if you think that that would
not be helpful
okay it looks like from the chat and
from the the yes answers in the
participants list that it would be
helpful so let's go through that cool so
we want to do maximum likelihood
training and specifically we want to be
able to maximize the log probability of
our data
the probability of our data is going to
be p of x
and
we're going to model p of x this
distribution with
this latent
by introducing a latent variable
and so
we can view this quantity
as the log of
um
this integral
or we're basically going to be
introducing
this latent variable z and then
integrating it out
and then taking the log
so this is the introduction of the
latent variable
now
what this kind of uh
what variational inference
and
intends to do
is to introduce
what's called the variational
distribution
uh
i'll denote it as q of z
and the goal of q z q z is going to aim
to try to help us
estimate uh the bound on our likelihood
and q of z
this can really be anything
uh
it has to
you don't want it to be it has to be a
proper distribution um of course
but as you can see in this equation it
doesn't really matter exactly what it is
um there are some choices of q that will
lead to a better
estimate
um often in practice you actually have a
variational distribution that is
conditioned
on
your your data point
uh
this will kind of allow you to get a
better
estimate of z for a certain data point
um but
in practice you can actually really
choose whatever you want to be on the
right hand side of the conditioning bar
okay so
this is still an equality
uh so far
and what you can do is you can move
this
q
over here and that gives you an
expectation
so this equals
the log of
the expectation under
q
of
p of x comma z
divided by q of z
dz
so we're still at equality here
um
and then uh and this is nice because now
we no longer have to compute this
integral over z
um we can essentially approximate this
now by just drawing samples from q of z
now here's where the bound is going to
come in so we want to be able to
estimate this by
drawing samples from q of z
but of course because we have this log
here um
that's a bit annoying because the
expectation over q isn't on the outside
and so like was mentioned in the chat we
can apply jensen's inequality and
basically bring the
x bring the log inside the expectation
uh
and i'll actually
write this out a little bit more and we
get something that looks like
this when we bring the log inside the
expectation
also i realize i shouldn't have a dc
here
okay um
and then
when we
kind of write this out in terms of the
first expression
uh that was on the slide we get
something that looks like
expectation under q of z
of log
p of x comma z
plus the entropy of q
uh and this is basically what was
written on the slide
so the reason why you may want to do
this is that
this allow this is something that we can
optimize
uh in particular if you set q
if for example you set q of z given x
to be a gaussian distribution
then you can represent this in closed
form and this is equal to
log of p of x given z
time
uh
plus log of
p of z
um we often set p of z to be like
a normal gaussian distribution
um and this is represented by a neural
network
so this may have parameters theta um
oftentimes you have the variational
distribution have parameters phi
and you optimize basically
when you take a maximum over this you
also take a
a max over this both respect both with
respect to phi and with respect to theta
okay so this is how we get this kind of
lower bound on the likelihood of our
data
and you can see that the term that i
just wrote out is the same as what's
written right here where you basically
get the
the likelihood after drawing samples
from q plus the entropy of q
uh intuitively you could also view this
as something that's trying to make
q of z
match
p of z
and then also maximizing the likelihood
of p of x given z when you're sampling
from
uh q of z
okay um
a couple more things to mention so p is
the model here um p of x given z is
represented with a neural network p of z
is represented with just some uh some
normal distribution
the reason why you represent it as this
is that the next layer of pz can
transform it into something that's more
interesting than that
so it doesn't actually really matter
this can be really any simple
distribution
uh and then q of z given x is often
called the inference network or the
variational distribution you can think
of it as something that
is kind of trying to infer the posterior
over z
given your data point
and again really like q can be whatever
you want um
but it's helpful to
uh
to optimize it with respect to
your bound
um and basically if you
if you maximize your bound then
you'll make um both respect to p and
with respect to q then you'll make it
tighter
um so that's why you want to kind of
yeah
optimize both q and p
um your model parameter is data your
variational parameters are phi
um
yeah
so any questions on
on this so far
okay um now one problem
that comes up is you need to back
propagate through
sampling
so
when you note that basically this
both of these terms depend on q in the
expectation
and we actually need to back propagate
into the parameters of q when we
optimize this
uh and so
that means that we need to um yeah if we
want to optimize q we need to back
propagate through this sampling process
and compute the derivative of the
expectation of q with respect to q
um and so the
the reparameterization trick
uh is kind of what allows you to to fix
this problem so if you set q to be a
gaussian distribution not only is it
easy to compute this kl divergence or
the equivalently this entropy
if you have
a gaussian q
then you can set
q to be equal to the mean of q
plus the standard deviation times some
noise where noise is just drawn from
this like standard gaussian distribution
and note that this function is
differentiable with respect to the mean
and variance
uh and so you can essentially
re-parametrize this distribution in
terms of this standard normal
distribution
and get something that is differentiable
with respect to the mean and the
variance and basically directly back
propagate into the mean and variance um
of the distribution which is pretty cool
okay um
there are a couple questions in the chat
so one question is how we leverage the
variational model to do supervised
learning tasks um i'll get this i'll get
into this in a second but kind of the
sneak peek into what it will look like
is you can think of the latent variable
well there's i guess there's different
ways to view it but you can think um in
a mid-learning model phi i becomes a
latent variable
and uh and your data becomes like dtrain
becomes your observed data
uh and so this will this framework will
allow us to do inference over our latent
variable
is asking can you explain the difference
between model parameters and variational
parameters
so
the model parameters
i guess there's a few different ways to
view it um
one is kind of mechanistic and one is
more theoretical but
i guess from a mechanistic standpoint
you can view the model parameters as
like
as representing
basically our
our model uh
basically modeling p of z and p of x
given z and we want to sample from this
model we only use
the the parameters of our model here
um the variational parameters are what
allow us to con to kind of
better compute this lower bound on our
likelihood
um and they're used during training
but they aren't at all used during
testing if you want a sample from this
model
um so that's kind of what they are from
a mechanistic point of view
and i guess also from a conceptual point
of view
okay
um
oh and lastly this is called amortized
variational inference because um
this inference network q is doing what's
called amortized inference because
instead of trying to optimize over z for
each example you're just trying to
estimate it by training a model that
kind of estimates it for you
so how might we do metal learning
leveraging these techniques
so
we
we can consider a setting where we have
kind of a black box neural network that
takes this input a training data set and
outputs a distribution over q of five
and then we use phi to make predictions
now in the standard vie we can view the
observed variables x the latent variable
z and we can derive a lower bound
now
in the metal learning setting
we now have an observed variable that's
our data and the latent variable which
is our task parameters
which is kind of an analogy that you can
make to the standard variational
autoencoder
and
you can also use this to derive
a lower bound on the likelihood of your
data that looks something like this
that's basically just analogous to the
lower bound of the vie
where you have some
kind of inference network over phi
you maximize the
likelihood of your data given phi and
then also
minimize the kl divergence between
your inference network and your prior
over your parameters
um what should cue condition on so in
the ve setting cue conditioned on x
uh in this setting we're going to be
conditioning q on our training data
uh so we're basically going to be doing
uh kind of
approximate inference to infer our top
specific parameters giving our training
data this this
inference network is going to look a lot
like the black box metal learner
um
this equation just kind of replaces
the probability of the data given phi is
just the probability the labels given x
test and pi
um and then lastly where do the meta
parameters come in
uh
the meta parameters will be part of the
the model so whenever we try to estimate
phi we'll condition that prediction on
theta on our meta parameters
um so theta here again is the
um
is the parameters of this neural network
so this is like
f theta for example
okay uh do you have a question
um so
yes well um
so the encoder
i guess the um
this is equivalent to the encoder or the
inference network in a vae
um that's basically you can view as
analogous to the f data right here okay
basically i learned as another network
because input will be d train and theta
and then we are getting phi out of it
which is the parameter right
yeah so it's basically this inference
network right here
um you could also condition on theta
here um this is kind of analogous to
like uh
so like a model that doesn't output all
the parameters it just outputs the
subset of the parameters
um
this just changes your your graphical
model a little bit if you condition on
theta here such that you get something
that looks more like
uh theta phi i and then when you
make predictions for why you get
something that looks also like this for
example
in your graphical model
so here i am using this network uh we
are getting input theta and data and
then inside and then
yeah so you basically have your
inference network that infers the task
specific parameters given your data and
your meta parameters you maximum
maximize the likelihood
of the of the labels under your top
specific parameters and then you
additionally have this kl term that
encourages this um basically encourages
this inference network to produce a
proper distribution over phi
is being optimized here
okay um so the final objective is here
for completeness um it's asking how many
samples do you use for training
uh in a vie
and and in this setting it's actually
often fine practice to just sample once
from this distribution although you'll
get kind of a tighter estimate
of your likelihood if you sample
multiple times
okay um so
this is one way to
produce a bayesian metal learning
algorithm
that
allows you to get a distribution over
your task specific parameters given in
your training
data um
and this allows you to get non-gaussian
distributions over y-test you don't
actually have to you're never actually
explicitly representing
the kind of distribution
of y-test
given x test d train and theta
instead what you're doing is you're
first representing
p of phi
and then you're representing p of y test
given
x test and phi
and because you don't actually have to
explicitly represent this
that makes it easier to represent more
complex distributions
it also produces a distribution over
functions it allows you to produce a
distribution over kind of task specific
parameters five
uh the downsides is that you can only
represent gaussian
distributions over p of phi i this is
important so that you can calculate the
ko and so that you can use the
re-parametrization trick
um
this is kind of more of a
it limits the expressivity of this
distribution
um in practice gaussian distributions
over parameters are
fairly effective uh for
yeah for up to distributions because
your parameters will be transformed in a
non-linear way to produce uh
predictions
okay
so that's kind of a way to use
variational inference to develop a
bayesian black box metal learning
techniques
i'm asking we can do a mixture of
gaussians too right um there is a way to
approximate the kale but it's difficult
to do the reparameterization trick with
the mixture of gaussians
there are some methods that try to
approximate
approximate it though
um and then asking for non-gaussian can
we not estimate kale using monte carlo
samples so you can't estimate the kl as
it's more difficult to back propagate
through
the sample at that sampling process
um which essentially the uh
basically that like this
reparameterization trick right here this
is really easy to do for gaussians it's
a lot harder to do for non-gaussians um
but if you're interested in this there
are methods that try to extend
variational auto encoders to other
distributions over your latent variable
but really the de facto thing to do is
to use a gaussian distribution
okay so this is a that was a black box
method that was kind of using a neural
network to produce a distribution number
phi i um what about some optimization
based methods
so
the first thing worth mentioning is uh
this paper here that actually cast
a
cast actually the kind of original
deterministic mammal algorithm
as
a bayesian method uh very approximately
and the way this works is we basically
have the same graphical model as before
um it's just written a little bit
differently where we're not writing out
the training the test sets separately
and
if we're trying to maximize
if we want to kind of
do
maximum likelihood in this model we're
maximizing the likelihood of the data
given our meta parameters
we can expand this out by introducing
the latent variable
uh phi i
in here and then integrate out phi i
and what this paper did is let's say
they said that well what if we very
crudely approximate this integral
by
the map estimate basically the value of
phi i that has the highest likelihood
this is a very crude approximation to
the integral um but if you have a very
peaky distribution it may be
not that crude uh
but in any cases it's a fairly accurate
approximation
but
under this crude approximation you can
show that
um
you could essentially show that mammal
corresponds to
doing inference in this graphical model
because of this prior result here this
prior result said that gradient descent
with early stopping
uh
corresponds to map inference under a
gaussian prior with a mean at the
initial parameters
and this was exact in the linear case
and approximate in the nonlinear case
um so essentially by making this crude
approximation and by also
making this approximation here in the
nonlinear case
this essentially provides a bayesian
interpretation of mammal where you can
view
mammals providing this map estimate
using that map estimate to estimate this
integral
and um
and therefore uh kind of
showing a correspondence between the
mammal algorithm
and this graphical model here
um of course this is all kind of very
crude and also
um under this interpretation we still
can't sample from this distribution here
so it's not very useful from the bajan
from the kind of standpoint of
representing distributions
so
there's a few different things that you
can do about this
um
one thing you could do is recall the the
black box metal learning approach that
we just talked about
and remember that this
this kind of inference network this this
variational distribution can really be
any arbitrary function
uh so from this standpoint you could
just put a gradient operator inside
queue
and
then kind of have it correspond to an
optimization
uh and so this course this is kind of
what this paper by ravi and beetson did
where they were cue basically
corresponded to running sgd
on the mean and variance of
neural network weights with respect to
your training data
um and basically uses all the machinery
they still optimize this objective they
just change the form of q
and the benefit of this is that it does
give you a way to run gradient descent
at test time while still giving you a
distribution
um again here
phi given theta is going to be modeled
as gaussian
um which
which may have its downsides
okay so this is the first way that we
could
um
then we could use it kind of
introduce a bayesian optimization based
metal learning algorithm
uh what about a non-gaussian posterior
so
uh the
kind of simplest thing that we could do
is to just do ensembles so basically the
technique where you train multiple
different neural networks
uh on different sub samples of the data
and so
really the simple simplest thing that
you could do is to trade an ensemble of
mammals
where you just trade m independent
mammal models
and you get something that looks like
this
uh and note that you can also use
ensembles with black box and
non-parametric methods as well
um
this
actually works pretty well uh but it
won't work well if your ensemble members
are too similar to one another
and this paper by kim at all
uh proposed to
use what's called stein variational
gradient to actually optimize for a more
diverse set of ensemble elements
um which basically just tries to push
different ensemble particles away from
one another
to get a more diverse ensemble of
mammals
and as a result optimized for a
distribution of particles that produce a
high likelihood
the benefit of this is that simple and
it tends to work well it also gives you
a non-gaussian distribution which is
nice
uh the downside is that of this is that
it tends to be pretty expensive because
you have to train complete m different
model instances which is uh which may be
a lot of computation and memory
um which is actually exactly what was
brought up in the chat
um you could do just kind of do this
just on the last layer only um
which will be a little bit cheaper
uh but then you only get a distribution
over that last layer which may be a
little bit less expressive
uh there's a question in chat about how
large is m i can't remember exactly how
many they used in this paper
uh it's
common to use something like three to
five uh so that if your computation
doesn't blow up too much
do you have a question
yeah uh
i meant to ask like for these mammals
like different mammal models so does it
matter if uh these models are trained on
the same data or like different sub
samples of data and bootstrap then after
yeah this is a good question so if you'd
use different bootstraps of your data
then
then it has a proper interpretation as
representing a distribution
in practice
people often
ignore that and just train different
models with a different initialization
and different a different order of mini
batches
and that often leads to
ensembles that work just as well as
using different samples of your data
um
yeah so in practice you can often kind
of skip the subsampling part and just
change the initialization and change the
um
change the the order of the mini batches
if you want something with a theoretical
uh
theoretical
kind of backing behind it then using
different bootstraps is the more correct
thing to do
okay
then lastly i want to talk briefly about
whether we can model non adopting
reaction posterior over all parameters
uh and we want to think about sampling
parameter vectors with the procedure
like
monte carlo
one more question actually from on the
last slide are they trained
independently or like each iteration
average loss from each model is used to
update the weight uh they tend to be
trained independently
okay um so this this
last method that we'll talk about
uh the intuition behind is that's trying
to learn a prior
over our parameters where
a kick in
any direction can put us into different
modes
of that function
um essentially something where we're
like maybe this is one mode of the
function that we want to learn where we
have a classifier that's along the lines
of like that discriminates on the means
of just smiling and young one classifier
that discriminates on smiling and
wearing a hat
and we want a prior here such that if
you add
a little bit of noise from this starting
point you end up in one of these two
modes
and then if you run gradient descent
you'll end up at
the kind of optimum for each of those
two modes
um i just put down two modes here
because it's easiest to visualize that
but in practice you may have more than
two modes
um
we're a bit low on time
so i might
kind of go through this quickly uh
the goal is we're going to be
representing both the distribution over
theta and a distribution over phi given
theta
and our goal is to be able to sample
from phi given our data
this is independent of x tests so you
can
fi once you condition on x train and y
train
uh
the yeah you basically get this
independent um
you this is
if we want to be able to approximate
this we get this kind of pretty
intractable integral
over
all possible parameters theta
which is not something that we want to
try to approximate
and kind of the intuition behind this
approach is that if we knew
p of i given theta
x train and y train for a single sample
from p of theta
then things get a lot easier so if we
knew what this was then we can just use
ancestral sampling to first sample from
p of theta and then sample from
a
sample from this distribution
so uh the way this works is we can
basically
like the bayesian interpretation of
mammal very crudely approximate this as
the map estimate of phi
which is
similar to running
gradient descent
and then do training on the full thing
with amortized variational inference
so kind of i guess the most important
thing though is what happens at test
time
uh
metatrading gives you a parameter a
distribution over theta
uh
and
what this corresponds to is basically
taking the mean of
this distribution
adding
sampling from theta which corresponds to
adding noise
to the mean
in correspondence to the variance
and then
running gradient descent which
approximately corresponds to sampling
from
pfi
and this is something that gives you a
kind of non-gaussian posterior over phi
it's also pretty simple at test time and
doesn't have to
be trained with an ensemble for example
um the downside is that involves a more
complex training procedure that uh i
didn't have kind of time to go through
in detail
okay um so to summarize the methods uh
v0 is just outputting a distribution
over y test
which is simple but can't reason about
uncertainty about over the underlying
function
we then talked about black box
approaches that can use variational
inference to represent a distribution
over a latent variable
this can represent non-gaussian
distributions
uh but it can only represent gaussian
distributions over phi i
then we also talked about optimization
based approaches where you could use
amortized inference ensembles or a
hybrid inference procedure
uh and they each have their own
pros and cons
um whether the first two are pretty
simple um
but uh have their very have kind of
various downsides such as being a
gaussian
a gaussian posterior over phi or having
to maintain m model instances
the last one is more complex uh but it
does give you a non-gaussian posterior
okay so this is kind of a summary of
the methods
one thing that i'd like to go over at
the end and want to make sure i have
time for is to talk about what you can
do when you have these basic metal
learning methods and how do you actually
evaluate a bayesian metal learning
method
so
one thing you could do is use a standard
benchmark like mini imagenet and this is
nice in that it's standardized it has
real images it's a good check that the
approach didn't break anything
but the downside is that metrics like
accuracy don't actually measure
whether your uncertainty is
accurate and the task may not exhibit
any ambiguity
representing uncertainty may not
actually be beneficial in these
circumstances
so
what i want to talk about briefly is
what are some better problems and
metrics for evaluating these kinds of
methods and it really depends on the
problem that you care about
so one thing that you could do is look
at kind of
some
toy 2d problems that allow you to
visualize things very easily
and specifically design them to have
ambiguity
so for example you could train a model
on both linear functions and sinusoid
functions add some noise to the data
points which are shown in purple such
that in some cases it's ambiguous
whether it's a sinusoid function or a
linear function
and then you can visualize the different
kind of functions that are predicted by
the model
and see that it can actually represent a
distribution over those functions so
for example in this case because all the
data points are up here it's unclear
exactly kind of which line is the true
line of the function
and in this case because the data points
are here and up here and because there's
noise in the data um it's unclear if the
function is a sinusoid or a linear
function
uh you can also design an ambiguous
classification problem where
you there's
all the problems in the
in the data distribution have circular
decision boundaries but you only give it
one data point
to infer the function from
and when you do that if you only give it
this green plus for example then it's
ambiguous where exactly the
the decision boundary lies and you can
actually visualize the different
functions you can visualize basically
the different functions that it's
estimating
based off of this single data point
so this is one example of how you can
visualize and measure whether or not the
uncertainty in the model is accurate
uh but of course these are toy problems
that may not translate to more complex
problems
another thing you could do is take a
more ambiguous problem
for example this paper looked at the
problem of being able to generate
images
given
just one view so for example it's given
this view
and it's ambiguous because there are
parts of the image that are excluded so
it doesn't know what the image will what
the object will look like when it's
flipped around 180 degrees
uh and by representing uncertainty
with like the versa approach which is uh
about it actually similar to one of the
things that we talked about today it can
represent this uncertainty in a much
more crisp way
than a uh a more naive approach
uh and this also leads to kind of a
better reconstruction accuracy because
this is an ambiguous keyshot learning
problem
another thing that you could do to
evaluate these methods is look at kind
of mode coverage and likelihood on
ambiguous tasks
so you could consider the set of
ambiguous classification tasks that i
talked about at the beginning
and then evaluate uh if you give it
something ambiguous where three of the
attributes are shared between the
positive and negative examples
and there are three potential modes that
share different numbers of attributes
then you could see like whether it's
able to cover all three of these modes
or basically how many modes
the
distribution will capture
when you sample from it and you can also
measure the the log likelihood of this
and then lastly one thing you could do
is look at what's called a reliability
diagram
and this is basically trying to see that
uh for data points that are more
accurate
for data points that
that it makes accurate predictions on is
it confident in those and for data
points that it is less accurate on is it
less competent in those so this is
plotting the confidence of that that the
classifier produces versus the accuracy
and if you basically see that
the the red bars follow this this line
that suggests that the confidence is
calibrated to the true accuracy
whereas if you look at kind of standard
mammal for example
it's not very calibrated and it doesn't
um
there's kind of a difference between
this line and where the bars are
okay
oh and then lastly and actually the kind
of most interesting thing that you could
do is actually evaluate whether it's
useful for active learning
so you can basically say
if i give it one or two or three or five
additional data points can it select
data points that lead to
kind of lower and lower error
compared to just randomly selecting data
points
so in both of these two experiments they
sequentially choose a data point
and they choose the data point with the
highest uh maximum predict with the
highest predictive entropy basically the
the highest uncertainty to be labeled
um versus just choosing a random data
point and you see that you can basically
get a more accurate classifier faster
with fewer labels
by leveraging this uncertainty
so i was asking can we use a simple
approach like mean field approximation
for variational inference will it work
well
so
uh
the
um these methods are actually already
doing something like mean failed
approximation where
the um
the
distribution over the um over the latent
variable is kind of an independent
gaussian distribution
um so it's basically assuming that each
of the dimensions in your latent
variable are independent from one
another
yeah so you could definitely use
something like normalizing flows to get
a um to get a non-gaussian distribution
uh there may be works that do something
like that but i don't know of any off
the top of my head is it like a benefit
of uh
doing like education like why do you
wanna do it because uh
is
yeah so my intuition is that if you can
represent a non-gaussian distribution um
you'll give more flexibility to the
metal learning process
and
with more flexibility you'll be able to
fit the data
the meta training data better
um that's a hypothesis uh it's not um
i mean perhaps there are cases where a
gaussian distribution is kind of
flexible enough
uh it also seems i guess using
non-gaussian distributions also i guess
placing a gaussian distribution seemed
like a pretty restrictive
constraint on the distribution that you
can represent uh so my guess is that you
would be able to better fit the data
with a non-gaussian distribution but
um
and it just kind of
seems aesthetically more appealing but
uh
i haven't verified this myself it
depends on the training
because
just having a highlighter doesn't really
mean that i'm getting a better learning
but yeah i mean like
having a non-reduction by adding so will
probably better
the possible like if you want to learn
directly this file are using that i can
still learn a distribution in it like
auto aggressive flow kind of inside
yeah so you can't
train like the flow model directly on
the parameters itself because you don't
have supervision on the parameters
uh but you can basically if you use it
to represent a distribution and then
use that um
you use that model to make predictions
on the data points then you should be
able to back propagate into the
into the model into your normalizing
flow model right last question so uh so
lastly we have this post-production
problem where we had your camera kind of
information uh
flow
so if we take the same thing in a
variation a lot of this and uh model
directly does it supposed to have better
regularization here like uh
it's not gonna
or like as good as like if we just use
this kind of a
yeah so all of the works
almost all the works that i talked about
today preceded the work that we did on
memorization uh so we that wasn't
something that we had really
an idea or a notion that we had
formalized
when we were working on on these
bayesian middling methods and when other
people were working on them
i do think that in principle these
methods should be more robust to
memorization but uh it's it's kind of a
very active area and not something that
uh that i've seen from these works yet
be a good project i like to look at this
kind of a basic approaches to like this
kind of more uh complex uh uh
post-production kind of problem
yeah i think that it could be reasonable
to explore whether whether these
bayesian metal learning methods uh
prevent memorization
what's your question
yeah i actually have two questions so
the first one is very naive so
so it's about the ensemble
approach so say if we only have five
mammals
in the ensemble so how can we make any
accurate uh
prediction for the distributions of the
pregnancies
so it really depends on what you're
using the ensemble for
uh people typically look at you use
ensembles to get a rough estimate for
uncertainty and the way that you can do
that with an ensemble is to look at how
much the ensemble elements disagree with
one another
and empirically people have found that
uh you only need like a few
ensembles to be able to get a reasonable
estimate of that sort of disagreement
um
but
yeah it is a little bit strange that
that you wouldn't need more than that
per se to get a good estimate um that's
kind of what people have observed in
practice
yeah so i have another question so
kind of today you watch the basic models
you're talking about kind of to capture
the
uncertainty in the models
so you also mentioned that there are
also uncertainties in the data
so i'm wondering if we know some of the
answers
in the data how can we leverage these
properties properties of the data
yeah so um
so a lot of these methods that can
capture model uncertainty will also be
able to capture
uncertainty in the data as well
um
capturing data uncertainty in the data
is like the easier kind of uncertainty
essentially um compared to capturing
uncertainty in the model
because it uh
when you kind of train a distribution to
the data it will um
yeah it should represent that
fairly readily
uh so i mean if we explicitly know the
uncertainties of the data for example we
know when we take an image we know for
example how against
how the noises are distributed in this
image
can we use
this kind of information
uh if you have knowledge of the noise in
your data then you could definitely
leverage that by
augmenting your kind of output
distribution typically
the when i say noise in the data i mean
more like noise in uh
in
kind of p of y given x because this is
what you're predicting
um so if you know like if you know the
distribution of noise in your labels
then you could basically like tack that
on attack that noise model onto the
the output of your neural network
uh in practice it that sort of noise
isn't that hard to learn though either
thank you so much
hi um so yeah
the noise and the data so version zero
was i think what you mentioned it's a
noise on the data um
and then the rest of the thing is like
uncertainty with the model parameters
right
so
in the last part of the lecture when uh
you were talking about the evaluation in
product like the reliability diagram
plots
wouldn't
just the uncertainty on data
um
show me this like i'm trying to figure
out
how i would interpret
uncertainty in the model with this um
like wouldn't if if i just did
uncertainty
over my data um and i did these plots i
could i could gather right like my
accuracies higher than
yeah so it depends on your test data if
your test data is out of distribution a
little bit
then you may be like inaccurate
on that data but over confident if you
don't measure your model uncertainty
if your data is if the data that you're
evaluating this is very much in
distribution like if you evaluate this
on your training data
then um
then that wouldn't that would be kind of
what you're saying would be just looking
at the data uncertainty i see i see so
then uh what you're suggesting is in
this reliability diagram on the
confidence part
one could one should do just uncertainty
over the model parameters right
for the
confidence um well so the confidence
score i guess
i can't remember exactly how they were
we're measuring this um
in their method but yeah you basically
want to plot those confidence in terms
of the um
well the the
the variance and the predictions that
the model is making essentially um
and if it is accurately representing
model uncertainty then you would expect
this
to
be more
calibrated or more correct especially
for
data that's a little bit out of
distribution
does that answer your question
yeah
thanks
okay sounds good
i'll see everyone next week